O sucesso do nosso algoritmo VQE depende muito
do estado e do circuit
que escolhemos para começar.
Sou Victoria Lipinska e neste vídeo
vamos explorar as opções
que temos para criá-los.
Vamos dar uma olhada mais de perto em todos os elementos
que temos em cada execução da parte quântica do VQE.
Começamos com o estado de referência,
às vezes chamado de estado inicial.
Executamos o estado de referência
por um circuit parametrizado chamado
forma variacional,
com uma escolha inicial de parâmetros,
e medimos o estado
na base do Hamiltoniano
após executá-lo pelo circuit
para obter o valor esperado. Agora
vamos percorrer cada um desses elementos,
começando pelo estado de referência.
Uma escolha típica para o estado de referência
é o estado zero.
Esse é o estado no qual um computador quântico
já é inicializado.
Para problemas de química quântica,
também se pode usar o chamado
estado de Hartree-Fock,
que é o resultado do
método de Hartree-Fock.
Em resumo, a teoria de Hartree-Fock
oferece uma maneira simples de construir
o estado de referência aproximando
o estado fundamental de um sistema quântico.
Ela encontra uma rotação
dentro do espaço de estados
que minimiza a energia do estado fundamental.
Por fim, o estado de referência
também pode ser muito específico para o problema,
e você pode querer escolher
um estado personalizado.
No caso em que você sabe quais propriedades
o seu sistema tem — por exemplo, simetrias
ou um número específico de elétrons
no estado —, você pode usar isso
para ter uma melhor convergência do algoritmo
VQE.
Escolher um bom estado de referência
é importante para a convergência.
Estados de referência que estão próximos
do estado fundamental
podem fazer o problema convergir
muito mais facilmente e rapidamente.
Igualmente importante
é a escolha dos valores iniciais dos parâmetros
que alimentamos na forma variacional.
Portanto, dependendo do estado de referência
e dos parâmetros iniciais,
podemos convergir rapidamente, lentamente
ou não convergir de jeito nenhum.
Vamos ver este gráfico
e, para fins de visualização,
vamos imaginar que o nosso espaço de parâmetros
tem apenas um parâmetro.
Um estado de referência muito bom
pode te deixar começar muito próximo
do estado fundamental final
e então a convergência será rápida.
Por outro lado, se começar muito longe
do estado fundamental aqui,
estado de referência
a, você terá que cruzar uma barreira de alta energia
levando a uma convergência muito lenta
ou nenhuma convergência.
Vamos discutir isso com mais profundidade
no módulo de otimização clássica
deste curso.
Vamos agora ver o circuit parametrizado
que age sobre o estado de referência, também conhecido como
forma variacional.
Quando esse circuit — o U de theta — age sobre o estado de referência,
ele produz o que chamamos de estado de teste,
psi de theta, ou às vezes ansatz.
É esse estado ansatz que é
então medido numa base apropriada
para obter o valor esperado
para a energia.
As formas variacionais
que estamos discutindo aqui
são motivadas pela química.
Mas lembra que existem também aquelas inspiradas
pelo aprendizado de máquina quântico
e outros algoritmos de
curto prazo, como algoritmos quânticos
de otimização aproximada.
Vamos discutir
algumas escolhas comuns para um ansatz de química.
Cluster acoplado unitário, ou UCC,
é o método originalmente proposto
na primeira publicação do VQE,
e é comumente usado em problemas
de química quântica.
Tipicamente,
quando parametrizamos um estado quântico,
trabalhamos com exponencialmente
muitos parâmetros.
No entanto, para tornar os circuits de preparação eficientes,
precisamos de um número polinomial de operações
e, portanto, de um número polinomial
de parâmetros.
O UCC é um exemplo de uma forma de preparar
um estado de teste com tal circuit,
e deriva do método de cluster acoplado,
que é o padrão ouro em química
quântica.
A escolha mais comum é o cluster acoplado unitário
de simples e duplas excitações,
ansatz UCCSD para abreviar.
Como o UCCSD é motivado pela configuração eletrônica específica de um problema,
precisamos garantir que temos um estado de referência
que reflita adequadamente o sistema.
Esse é o estado de Hartree-Fock.
O ansatz UCCSD geralmente fornece
uma boa aproximação do estado fundamental,
pois captura excitações eletrônicas simples e duplas
numa determinada molécula.
O número de parâmetros no UCCSD escala
quadraticamente com o número de
orbitais de spin.
O UCCSD pode ser muito bem
adaptado a um problema,
mas, infelizmente, o escalonamento quadrático
ainda leva a circuits muito profundos
que são difíceis para os computadores quânticos atuais.
É por isso que pesquisadores da IBM propuseram
uma abordagem mais heurística,
onde se pode adaptar uma forma variacional
ao hardware subjacente,
resultando num circuit
eficientemente executável.
Ou seja, os estados de teste são parametrizados
por gates quânticos
e são adaptados
ao dispositivo físico disponível.
Esta é uma abordagem muito heurística
que é amigável ao hardware.
Com base nesses exemplos, vamos dar uma olhada
no espectro de possibilidades
que temos para expressar
a nossa forma variacional.
Muitas dessas
já estão implementadas no Qiskit,
então encorajo você a experimentar por conta própria
qual é a mais adequada
para o problema que está tentando resolver.
Olhando o gráfico, por um lado
temos as formas variacionais
muito heurísticas.
Quando a especificidade do problema é baixa, mas
elas são projetadas para ser implementadas
no hardware real.
Elas também são altamente expressivas, tudo no sentido
de que é possível expressar
muitos estados quânticos com elas.
No entanto,
um problema que pode ocorrer em fase posterior
da otimização clássica
é encontrar
o chamado platô árido,
que discutiremos no próximo módulo.
Por outro lado,
temos o cluster acoplado unitário altamente específico ao problema
que funciona excelentemente em química clássica, mas
é difícil de implementar no hardware quântico
por causa das grandes profundidades de circuit.
Em geral, os cálculos
podem ser mais bem-sucedidos se você puder,
primeiramente, escolher um estado de referência
e um conjunto inicial de parâmetros
que criem um estado ansatz
próximo ao estado fundamental.
E segundo, evitar parâmetros desnecessários.
Eles tanto introduzem
maior profundidade de circuit sem retorno
quanto criam um espaço de parâmetros maior
para pesquisar, levando a platôs
na otimização clássica.
Quais parâmetros são necessários é uma questão
específica do problema
que requer reflexão cuidadosa.
Vamos falar sobre onde o nosso convidado de honra,
o Hamiltoniano, está se escondendo em tudo isso.
Como aprendemos na seção anterior,
o Hamiltoniano após o mapeamento de qubit
é representado como uma soma de
cadeias ponderadas de operadores de Pauli.
Por fim, no entanto,
queremos avaliar o valor esperado
do nosso Hamiltoniano sobre o estado ansatz
produzido pela forma variacional.
Por sorte, a mecânica quântica é simpática e linear,
e é isso que usaremos
para obter o valor esperado.
Veja como funciona.
Sabemos que o Hamiltoniano é uma soma ponderada de operadores de Pauli.
Por causa da linearidade,
o valor esperado da soma
é igual à soma dos valores esperados
de cada cadeia de Pauli.
Bem, isso é ótimo porque, como você já sabe, medir na base de Pauli
é tão simples quanto uma rotação
da base de medição padrão.
Em vez de medir o valor esperado
sobre esse enorme Hamiltoniano representado
como uma soma, primeiro avaliamos os valores esperados dos termos individuais
e somamos ao final
com os pesos correspondentes.
É por isso que em muitos recursos
você verá apenas rotações de qubit único
após o ansatz.
Isso é o que implementa o Hamiltoniano
em cada execução do circuit.
No próximo vídeo,
exploraremos o que acontece
durante a etapa de otimização clássica.
Te vejo lá.